Ngày mùi thằng sau, vì bán nhân dân tình kinh dàng làm việc với tổng công ty cảnh hàng không Việt Nam,
A.C.V. nhằm chào đổi, thảo lận về công tác quán lý.
Hai thác cảnh hàng không dạch giá và chiến khai nghĩ quyết số không một vì mở giộng cảnh hàng không quốc tế
phù quốc phục vụ hội gí à pek hai nghĩ khu trọng hai miệm bệnh.
Theo quy hoạch đến năm 2019, cảnh hàng không dạch giá đặt cấp 4C, công xuất một chữ hành khách 1 năm,
đong vai trò là cảnh quốc nội và sinh bay quân sự cấp hai.
Ui bán nhân dân tình kinh dàng để xuất A.C.V. đầu tư đường cất hạc cảnh để tiếp nhận các lại tổ bây giờ A.C.V.
đầu tư nhận ra bảo đảng một chữ hách, khoảng thành chức năm 2020.
Lãnh đạo tình kinh dàng cũng cho biết với định rường xáp nhập Áng dàng, kinh dàng và phát triển dú liệt.
Tình đặt một tiêu phát triển xinh bay dạ thành khu vực hàng không đà chức năng,
kinh đối chính lượng với phù quốc và phát triển vùng đồng bằng xong cử lòng.
Bởi xanh bay phù quốc, tình kinh dàng được xa quý lựa trọn nhà đầu tư trong nước và tổ chức thực hiện dự án đầu tư mở giọc.
Bảo đảng đúng quy định pháp lột, công hai, mình bà không để sẻ ra thức thoát, lãnh phí.
A.C.V. Cám kế phối hợp chất chế với địa phương, bảo đảng khách thác áng toàn, hiệu quả trong khoảng chiếm mở giống vào vận hành xanh bay.